now here's an inside look at the $17,000
a night luxury apartment where Kim was
held at gunpoint
the two-story complex which is
considered a safe alternative to big
hotels has been frequented by stars like
Leonardo DiCaprio and Madonna
Kim and Kanye who prefer the top level
penthouse stayed in the same spot when
their world when wedding stopped in
Paris two years ago Kim Kardashian has
been instagramming photos of herself and
her sisters tweeting her whereabouts
police will of course be looking at
those tweets at the Instagram account to
see if perhaps she inadvertently gave
away clues that may have helped the
robbers in their planning
Kim flashed her 4.5 million dollar
engagement ring on snapchat just two
hours before she was robbed she also
showed off her diamond and gold grill
but of the reported 11 million dollars
in jewelry that was stolen the 20 carat
Lorraine Schwartz bling which is
actually the second ring Kanye gave her
was her most prized possession
favorite accessory I mean my engagement
ring that I wear all the time is
definitely my all-time favorite
accessory she spent the day here in New
York City reunited with her kids north
and state who thankfully were not in
Paris at the time of the robbery they
were here in New York with Kanye family
friends and they're not